ces dernières semaines j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous rencontrer pas tous
mais un certain nombre d'entre vous
quand même et ça a été l'occasion de
constater qu'il ya un sujet qui vous
intéresse tout particulièrement mes
fesses donc pas vraiment mes fesses non
en réalité ce qui vous intéresse la
question qu'on va le plus posé que ce
soit en convention dans le métro dans
les toilettes des bars donc à cette
grande question c'est comment va
cyril hanouna alors ton second pas suivi
non qui le dessus par un proche de bab à
les gens parlent du tatouage que j'ai
sur la fesse alors ok dit comme ça ça
peut faire chelou mais vous irez voir la
vidéo vous comprendrez bref je vous
avais promis de vous donner des
nouvelles de temps en temps alors je
vous emmène avec moi à ma deuxième
séance de la terre
[Musique]
alors petit résumé de l'épisode
précédent pour ce corps et a suivi après
ma première séance de laser pour retirer
le tatouage ya deux mois maintenant que
j'ai tiré deux enseignements d'abord ça
fait mal et ensuite le tatouage n'a pas
bougé donc aujourd'hui je retourne pour
la deuxième séance avec deux objectifs 1
comprendre si c'est normal
1 et 2 bat le tatouage commence un petit
peu assez facile allez c'est parti
une petite précision hier soir je fais
la fête j'ai un peu abuser des bonnes
choses les peu dormi je me suis réveillé
tard donc j'ai pas mangé je suis l'agent
lapointe du scientifique ça va être
intéressant de voir à mes réactions à la
séance et à la douleur près de façon
plus globale on va pas se mentir c'est
complètement con ne fait pas ça très
beau les dents c'est trop tard pour
reculer
j'y vais à longvic
voilà
voilà si tu es bon j'ai pas fait de
malaise mais je vais quand même pas trop
le fier au nom je vais aller manger un
petit morceau et je vous raconte tout ça
après voilà j'ai mangé j'ai même fait
une petite sieste pas vous mentir
bon alors j'ai eu la réponse aux deux
questions que je me posais n'attendra
pas le médecin c'est normal qu'après la
première séance on voit pas vraiment la
différence au niveau du tatouage mais
d'après lui le fait qu'il ait vu des
petites réactions blanche à la surface
du tatouage la dernière fois pendant la
première séance et même pendant la
deuxième c'est signe que l'encré bien
détruites donc ça fonctionne c'est
jusque apparemment il y allant crd en
dessous qui remonte aussi à la surface
du coup visuellement on voit pas trop la
différence mais en vrai la quantité
d'encre diminue alors du coup il va
proposer d'augmenter l'intensité du
laser j'ai dit ok pour que ça marche
mieux quoi la douleur avec du coin j'ai
demandé aussi à partir de quand les
effets seront visibles vraiment parce
que quand le tatouage va commencer à
placer assez bas il sait pas en fait
parce que ça dépend de la quantité
d'encre et de la qualité de lancre du
tatouage et sa vue de l'extérieur il
peut pas savoir donc faut être patient
quoi
petit bilan visuel du coup ça c'est mon
tatouage le matin quelques heures avant
la deuxième séance
ça c'est mon tatouage quelques heures
après la fin de la deuxième séance
ça c'est à toi le lendemain et ça c'est
à tout âge deux jours après bon alors du
coup on va dire que c'est pas encore ça
mais vraiment le médecin valeur
tellement confiant que moi disons que je
suis rassuré et puis il reste encore
quatre séances du coup et la prochaine
c'est dans deux mois
juste avant l'été avait alors le coup de
faire ça en ayant très peu dormi pas
manger et fait la fête la veille je vous
confirme j'ai testé pour vous ne faites
pas ça jamais pas une bonne idée du tout
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les
commentaires ce qu'il voulait que je
continue à vous donner des nouvelles de
cyril de temps en temps en attendant
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]